in the previous video you saw how you
can use vectorization
to compute the predictions the lowercase
A's for an entire training set all sort
of at the same time in this video you
see how you can use vectorization to
also perform the gradient computations
for all M training examples again all
sort of at the same time and then at the
end of this video we'll pull all
together and show how you can derive a
very efficient implementation of
logistic regression so you remember that
for the gradient computation what we did
was we computed DZ one for the first
example riskily a one minus y one and
then DZ 2 equals a 2 minus y 2 and so on
so on and so on for all my training
examples so what we're going to do is
define a new variable D capital Z is
going to be DZ 1 DZ 2 right DZ m again
all the D lowercase D variables stacked
horizontally so this would be a 1 by M
matrix or alternative VA M dimensional
real vector now recall that from the
previous slide we'd already figured out
how to compute capital a which was this
a 1 through am and we had defined
Capital y as y 1 through ym also you
know stacked horizontally so based on
these definitions um maybe you could see
for yourself that DZ can be computed as
just a minus y because this is going to
be equal to now a 1 minus y1 through the
first element a2 minus y2 in the second
element and so on and so and so this
first elements a 1 minus y1 is exactly
the definition of DZ 1 the second
element is exactly definitely Z 2 and so
on
so with just one line of code you can
compute all of this at the same time now
in the previous implementation we've
gotten rid of one for loop already but
we still had this second for loop over
training examples
so we initialize DW to zero to the
vector of zeros but then we still have
to loop over training examples where we
have PW plus equals x1 times d z1 for
the first training example DW plus
equals x2 DZ 2 and so on so we do the M
times and then you know DW 2y equals by
M and similarly for B write DP was
initialized as 0 and then DB plus equals
V Z 1 DP plus equals D Z 2 down to you
know DZ m and then D be divided equally
M so that's what we had in the previous
implementation we'd already gotten rid
of one for loop so le is now DW is a
vector and we went separately you know
updating DW 1 DW 2 and so on so we've
gotten rid of that already but we still
have a for loop over the m examples in
the training set so let's think these
operations in vectorize them here's what
we can do for the vectorized
implementation of DB what is doing is
basically summing up all of these
disease and then dividing by M so DB is
basically 1 over m sum from I equals 1
through m of DZ I and well all the
disease are in that a row vector and so
in Python what you do is in Flynn you
know 1 over m times n P dot sum of D Z
right so just take the variable and call
the NP but some function on it and that
would give you DB
how about DW I'll just write out the
correct equations you can verify the
right thing to do DW x will be one of M
times the matrix x times DZ transpose
and to kind of see why that's the case
this is equal to one of M then the
matrix X is X 1 through X M right
stacked up in columns like that and DZ
transpose is going to be DZ one down to
DZ m like so and so if you figure out
what this matrix times this vector works
out to be this turns out to be one over
m times X 1 DZ 1 plus dot dot dot plus
XM DZ m right and so this is a n by 1
vector and this is what you actually end
up with what DW because DW was taking
these you know x ID zi and adding them
up and so that's what exactly this
matrix vector multiplication is doing
and so again with one line of code you
can compute G W so the vectorized
implementation of the difference
calculations is just this you use this
line to implement DB and use this line
to influence DW and notice that without
a for loop over the training sites you
can now compute the updates you want to
your parameters so now let's put all
together into how you would actually
implement logistic regression so this is
our original highly inefficient non
vectorized implementation where um so
the first thing we've done in the
previous video was get rid of this
volume right so instead of looping over
DW 1 DW 2 and so on we have replaced
this with a vector value DW and just say
this is DW + equals X I which is now a
vector times DZ I but now we'll see that
we can also get rid of not just a for
loop below but also
get rid of this volume so here's how you
do it so using what we had from the
previous slides you would say Capital Z
is equal to W transpose X plus B and
code you write is capital Z equals NP
dot W transpose X plus B and then a
equals sigmoid of capital T so you've
now computes it all of this and all of
this for all the values of iron mix on
the previous line we said you would
compute DZ equals capital A minus
capital y so now you compute all of this
for all the values of I then finally DW
equals 1 over M X D Z transpose and DB
equals one of em you know and P dot some
DZ so you've just done for propagation
and back propagation really computing
the predictions and computing the
derivatives on all M training examples
without using a for loop and so the
gradient descent update then would be
you know W gets updated as W minus the
learning rate times DW is just computed
above and B is updated as B minus a
learning rate times DB so sometimes it's
really cool inserted it notices on
assignment but I guess I haven't been
totally consistent to that notation but
with this you have just implemented a
single iteration of gradient descent for
logistic regression now I know I said
that we should get rid of explicit
folders whenever you can but if you want
to implement multiple iterations of
gradient descent then you still need a
for loop over the number of iterations
so you if you want to have a thousand
iterations of gradient
you might still need a full loop over
the iteration number because and also
most folders like that and I don't think
there's any way to get rid of that for
loop but I do think it's incredibly cool
that you can implement at least one
iteration of gradient descent without
needing to use a full loop so that's it
you now have a highly vectorize and
highly efficient implementation of
gradient descent or register direction
there's just some one more detail that I
want to talk about in the next video
which is in our description here I
briefly alluded to this technique called
broadcasting broadcasting turns out to
be a technique that pison an umpire
allows you to use to make certain parts
of your code also much more efficient so
let's see what some more details of
broadcasting in the next video